hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 7 video whole bunch
of legends of tomorrow set up so
everybody like Chuck your vodka out grab
a glass of whiskey and let's go just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet and just a reminder my
reverse flash ring giveaway is new this
week all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so there's there's a whole bunch
of magic stuff for the back half and the
seasons that they're teasing with damian
darhk-- but mostly this is like legends
of tomorrow stuff starting with top 5
WTF felicity
vs all olicity I love that Felicity was
so pissed at herself for going away with
Oliver I feel like this is a big strike
if you hate olicity this is a big
episode for you everybody on the team
has their own demons that they deal with
and you don't really see them until they
get super stressed out like when Thea
goes crazy because the bloodlust like
Sara did in this episode or last season
when Oliver went super crazy I can't be
with you it can't be the arrow and be
this Oliver Queen guy he I mean he came
full circle and they worked together at
the end
felicity achieved that same arc within
the same episode you know thanks to help
from her mother what I think the writers
are saying with this is that there's not
gonna be any kind of wedding rings
happening anytime soon that still exists
I mean a little price they'll come up so
eventually when they do break up and I
definitely do think that they're gonna
break up for the end of the season you
just see them part ways amicably like
look we have a bigger responsibility
we're gonna have to put this thing
between us on hold Marc Guggenheim at
the beginning of the season was like
well their relationship will last longer
than it has in the past which i think is
just code for yeah they're definitely
gonna break up pretty soon my favorite
Felicity moment though was just like at
the beginning of the episode when you
see her in that trash pile of Cheetos
and energy drinks I feel like there's a
missed opportunity for an integration
they're like I hope their brand
integration manager was calling Cheetos
like look we have a ton of Cheetos in
this episode please send us some money
on the number 4 though barren writer in
the flashbacks is looking for a gift
from the Ancients what it is we have
absolutely no idea just that it's
somewhere underneath the water in that
Cove there at this point the flashbacks
almost seem like an afterthought but I
do think they'll connect more with
modern-day real soon I'm just expecting
those markings that Baron Reiter
uncovered to connect with what's going
on with the stuff that damian darhk--
has like his magical artifacts even if
one of the objects the damian darhk--
has is not on the
I think that Oliver will learn something
that will help him deal with damian
darhk-- later they did say they wanted
the flashbacks to be a little bit more
independent of present-day like they
they didn't want to have characters from
the flashback show up in present-day so
it's slightly more disconnected that
it's been in seasons past but this thing
with ELISA ratar-o this actress here
that's gonna continue to develop so she
might wind up being something of a
spiritual guide for Oliver with without
him realizing it on the number three
though hey mom
totally love you no spoilers please in
case you forgot the last time she showed
up in town she told Quentin that she was
now dating someone and living in Central
City so we might see her in a future
episode of the flash or they might they
might refer to her at this point she's
on the level with Oliver's child like
I'm not expecting her to come on the
show anytime soon but she definitely
still exists and she's still there
really I think the biggest casualty in
the episode was team arrow progression
because they spent most of the time
developing what's going to be going on
with legends of tomorrow like you know
setting up the atoms shrinking ability
setting up Sara to become the white
canary like giving her a reason to go
away like oh I have this bloodlust I
have to go away and deal with it I need
some time
you know quote-unquote time to deal with
it she'll have all the time she needs
pretty soon they even tease that on rip
hunter's time ship which I haven't seen
pictures of yet it's actually like a
really big ship there's going to be
something of a romance between the atom
and the white canary but neither my
number two WTF mister terrific and
Felicity head into battle so it's always
a little bit like they're scenes are
mostly meant for comedy mister terrific
reminded us that he's an Olympic
medalist in the decathlon so he's
actually pretty badass but they're
mostly using him for comedy on the show
so push comes to shove in a future
episode or like the back half of the
season we'll probably see him throw down
and kick some serious ass but I love
Felicity's joke before they hit in where
she's like I don't think that our
company health plan covers supernatural
dismemberment you always hear them
referenced magic in some way I like I
like the consistency even when damian
darhk-- was fighting Oliver which was
actually more of a distraction he was
really just there to keep damian darhk--
busy but on a my number one WTF damian
darhk-- reveals the next stage in his
plan for the city he unfolds his box and
it looks like it's magical circuitry
like there's mechanical parts that
require the dwarf star alloy to be
powered but there are also magical runes
now here's a bit of a stretch it looks a
lot like the markings on a mother box
now
that would imply really really big
things things that I never thought that
arrow would ever be able to do but
they're doing legends of tomorrow
they're doing time travel time masters I
guess they could do New Gods at a
certain point some of the fantastical
things of Jack Kirby's fourth world
would fit a lot better in this TV
universe that they have then in the
super serious movie universe but I'd
never think in a million years they'd
ever be able to do like a real version
of Darkseid or the New Gods or anything
like that so it remains to be seen what
this actually is but it does look like
circuitry in what kind of tiny box
shaped object do you know about that
requires dwarf star alloy levels of
power to activate there just aren't that
many things in the DC Universe that I
could think that would need that so I do
think that he's going to use that box as
a portal of sorts like he talked about
breathing new life into the city into
this world cackling villain monologue
now within like the arrow flash legends
of tomorrow universe we haven't seen a
lot of the spirit world or demonology or
any of the characters associated with
those comics like each organ so I'm
curious to see if damian darhk-- is
communing with someone like Trigon like
a really big figure in the DC Universe
or if it's gonna be someone that they
just make up like someone original to
the show
Baron writers specifically called out to
the ancients now that's kind of a
generic term we don't know who those are
but I'm guessing that's also who damian
darhk-- is trying to work with but let
me know in the comments though what do
you think damian darhk-- meant when he
said breathe new life into this world
and and just to talk about the
post-credits like there was just like a
little bit of poster all obviously like
the atom went off he's like felicity
you're gonna be in charge till I decide
to come back from the dead
more legends of tomorrow set up and then
you see detective Lance with Felicity's
mom not really expecting anything big to
go on there and you can look into that
as much as you want but they did confirm
the Thea will have something going on
with this campaign manager so as much as
damian darhk-- is gonna royally screw
everyone at least they'll have someone
to make out with as the world comes to
an end whole lot of tongue going around
on the flash and arrow this week I feel
like as we get closer to sweeps week
that's like a big week for advertisers
in the United States that's when you
tend to see the more sensational things
happen so like you start seeing more
people have sex you see that they
crossover episodes so like that's why
next week on the flash we're gonna see
Gorilla Grodd you're gonna be a huge
special-effects episode and then
there'll be a week break and then the
week after that in December we're going
to see the big crossover
so than the midseason finales there's
actually a ton of DC Universe
Marvel Universe and Star Wars universe
stuff happening in December they're
gonna drop a new trailer for Batman V
Superman which is actually coming out in
March which is like way earlier than big
movies like that normally do we got the
first trailer for Captain America Civil
War and x-men apocalypse dropping with
Star Wars The Force awakens so it is
gonna be like the biggest December I
think we've had in a long long time what
I'm gonna try and do is post agents of
shield tomorrow morning then there's new
Star Wars footage and hopefully I'll
have time to do a Supergirl video too
we'll see we'll see if I can get three
videos out tomorrow I don't know if it's
gonna happen but well you guys wait for
that stuff you can click here for this
week's episode of the flash if you
haven't seen it yet zoom versus Barry is
so much fun
and you can click here for the Jessica
Jones trailer that I just posted so much
david tennant creepiness that's gonna be
so awesome thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight